I've waited for whom testing one two  three  we're on we're here to investigate a  patient that killed three innocent  teenagers on a Halloween in 1978 he was  shot by his own psychiatrist and taken  into custody that night and spent the  last 40 years in captivity hello Michael  I have something you might like to see  everyone in my family like turns into a  nutcase this time of year yeah I mean  your grandmother is Laurie Strode she  was almost a murdered wasn't it her  brother converted all those babysitters  yeah it was not her brother that's the  main if people made up do you know that  I pray every night that he would escape  hey Belle did you do that for so I can  kill him the bus crashed  what bus crash Michael escaped  excuse me somebody's in here it's waited  for this night he's waiting for me  I'm waited for him  you don't believe in the boogeyman  my  [Music]  you should can close the closet door  [Music]  you